[Music]
so this is it [__] ksi log and
Paul to the rematch been watchin fightin
since I was a kid I've seen legends who
had so much skill lay on the line for
world titles and yet I've never been
more invested in a fight in my life
in one corner ksi the king of English
YouTube so many youtubers all their
careers to him the charisma he had was
just unparalleled back in 2004 and when
everyone was staying in their Lane he
was breaking out of every single box
anyone tried to put him in repeatedly
comedy gaming music now fighting an
all-round born entertainer in the other
corner - Captain America log and Paul he
is the embodiment of what people around
the world see as an all-american boy
blond-haired blue-eyed kid just handsome
charismatic athletic contain his hand to
anything and smashing and a soaring rise
to success the likes of which we hadn't
seen before on YouTube and these two
have had a bigger impact on my career
than any other youtubers I remember when
I first seen JJ's videos when I started
YouTube and I instantly realized how
[__] my videos were and it wasn't
because he spent a lot of money making
them he just translated his humor across
on videos so much better he had a brain
for comic timing he had something that
nobody else had and he was the levels
ahead of everyone back then and I
remember thinking [__] like I'd love to
do a podcast with that guy like he could
make your whole career how great would
that be sitting in my little house in
New Castle thinking personal [__]
chance of that ever happened and I never
thought I'd get a podcast GG but I tamed
him anyway I thought [__] it next thing
I know he's on the weight of my [__]
studio it's actually happening I was
shocked it was nothing in it for him
just purely to help me I'll be forever
grateful for that my first experience
with Logan wasn't quite as good and if
I'm honest with you I thought it was an
[__] and he knows that I think
everyone knows that and it was a snap
judgment of the worst version of Logan
you could see without knowing the real
him in any way so I made a video about
what Logan did and weirdly his
name alone help me because now four
million people know who the [__] I am
that had a huge impact on my life after
that Logan didn't want me commentating
the fight naturally I was brutal we went
back and forward on a couple of videos
and then he rang me up and we hashed it
out like men and he apologized and
showed he wasn't just this guy who did
this one bad thing but he actually was a
decent bloke and made a [__] big
mistake but was learning from it and
actually let me commentate at the fight
and became a friend of mine he earned my
respect a lot through that and for both
of these guys to want me to comment here
on that fight it might not have been a
big deal to them but it meant everything
to me and since then even on JJ's last
night in the UK he's flying to Vegas the
next morning he's probably stressed out
probably wants to be chillin with his
girlfriend I asked him a favor come can
we do a podcast mate he still makes that
time to come out of his way to do this
before he sets off for Vegas top guy
Logan flies to the UK probably jetlag to
[__] gorzan does a press conference
probably just wants to chill out he's
only in London for 12 hours and he's
wrecked he still makes time come on my
podcast and help me out they both helped
me so much it's a shame that I'm gonna
have to sit and watch them beat the [__]
out each other for monastery because you
don't want to say to people you like a
lot but it's necessary I want one of
these guys to finish this fight not
because I want to see either of them
hurt you know I hope that they [__]
get up and everything's fine but if they
need that both of them need to know who
is the best and that's why they're doing
this they so [__] rich they don't
need to get into boxing they don't need
to take punishment but they're willing
to put it all on the line anyway it's
just to find out and I respect the [__]
out of it and lastly on their character
when I had a bit of a crap time this
year they both reached out to me
privately and I appreciate that but now
I've got to talk about the last fight so
I watched a fight again and there was a
few things apparent in the earlier
rounds for me now looking back at it
Logan looked the more natural boxer had
better punch in accuracy his technical
boxing in terms of the way was throwing
punches looked more like a boxer he was
faster he was stronger when he hit
jayjay he hurt him more than when JJ hit
him there's a certain connection that
your mind has with your body when you
are a trained athlete when you spent
years using your body in a competitive
environment like log and did in
there's an advantage rogen just has over
JG his body is going to be more in tune
with what his mind wants it to do
because of years of having to do that
that JJ just doesn't have and that was
on display in those early rounds and
there's a Mormon early in the fight
first round Logan is just tagging JJ and
JJ isn't he's not knocked out but he's a
bit discombobulated and I'm watching
that back now thing and if that happens
again where there's no head guards
there's smaller globes and Logan has had
14 months extra training to know when
your opponent is like that and he is
discombobulated do you move in for the
[__] kill we're potentially looking
at a finish in that fight now now once
again
JJ's also had 14 months to be aware of
this but I'm just looking at our first
fight and thinking wow and that is
during a fight where Logan had less
boxing training than JJ JJ fought before
he'd beat Joella if you're a ksi fund
that should be concerning you know if
your K size coaches vedalam very good
friends with that will be of concern you
can't end up in that position again
where he's just teeing off on you
because if that happens again we're
gonna say the fight finished I can't be
any more [__] real than that color
like it's a serious [__] now before
everyone jumps to conclusions which I
know you're already doing there's a
chill son and saying that I like where
he says the person who wins the fight
isn't the best fighter it's the person
who fights best and JJ didn't fight his
best that night by his own admission he
started slowly and I know he's not gonna
want to let that happen again by the end
of the third round we'd seen log and
have a lot of success through some of
those physical advantages I've mentioned
with those physical advantages comes
disadvantages Logan has these fast
twitch fibers that enable him to be very
quick very strong like what you see with
professionals like Conor McGregor but
the downside of that is it's very hard
to continuously be that quick and
powerful and like Conor McGregor you see
Logan taya and he is slumped on his
stool at the end of that third round
breathing out his ass now if Logan had
been boxing more than three months he
would have known to take this round off
you know get your gas tank back avoid
those power shots from JJ and just
recover a bit so that you've got enough
to finish the fight strong but JJ was
not about to let that happen this is
where JJ strengths kicked in the stamina
that he's got this freak natural stamina
that means he gets better as fights go
on a JJ's superior movement was able to
count finally because with Logan's
slowing down and his power not being as
brutal JJ was able to take a few more
risks to get inside to rough him up to
make it a fight and less of a boxing
match and that's where JJ really found
his success in this fight and if he
wants to win the next fight he's gonna
have to do that a lot sooner
now despite JJ being a little bit more
experienced than Logan coming into that
fight he was still a very inexperienced
boxer so he's now in a position where
he's got a ghast fighter in front of him
but he's not punching accurately enough
to fully take advantage of the situation
he's in and after training at the dolls
gym I can tell you now that that
accuracy will be there in the next fight
in the fifth round despite all the
pressure JJ was putting on Logan Logan
still caught him hardiman in a little
bit of danger there JJ's trying to use
head movement to get out of this spot
but Logan is tagging him over and over
and over again now JJ weathered that
storm when you're the smaller man and
you're coming in against a powerhouse
like Logan the likelihood is that's
gonna happen again at some point in the
next fight and that could be the
difference between JJ winning the fight
and losing the fight the one thing we
found out about JJ in that first fight
as he's tough as old boots and he's
gonna need that cuz a big unit like
Logan Paul isn't gonna go down easy if
that current thinks he's [__] her
he's gonna be swinging for the fences
mark my words and if he lands you'll
know about it in the final round we see
in Logan's cardio look levels below JJ's
JJ was all over him and if he'd had more
experience this would be where he
finished that fight was there for him
just couldn't put the pieces together at
the end a lot of people just think Logan
wasn't fit enough but I think a lot got
to him that night the adrenaline is
pumping it's the first ever fight JJ's
done that occasion before people booing
him he's surrounded by his family
backstage he even said this time there's
no family coming backstage because that
absorbed so much out of him before he
even walked out and that just shows the
level of detail that both of these guys
are going to be thinking on this is like
we'll title series for them despite all
of Logan's early success towards the end
of that fight there was only one per
gonna win this and that was jayjay his
cardio was on point he had the
experience of fighting Joella before
like he hadn't had the adrenaline dump
that Logan had clearly had and he didn't
have the size to carry around our Logan
hut and he was coming on strong and
Logan barely hung on at the end Logan's
gonna know now he can't allow that to
happen to him again he is gonna have to
have done the work so that when JJ tries
to drag him into those deep waters that
you can survive coming into the rematch
so much importance needs to be placed on
who these guys are surrounded by
although I've given an edge to Logan
they're clearly physically closely
matched I mean no one dominate at that
entire fight there and they both have
different strengths and weaknesses so
what information is in their brain is
gonna make all the difference to win in
this fight in team ksi we've got vidal
riley an elite-level amateur silver
medalist for Team JP in team maverick
we've got Shannon the cannon breaks
two-time heavyweight champion of the
world let's go champ it's so different
Shannon is twice the age of Vidal vadai
was like the future of boxing Shannon's
at the end of his boxing career in
theory Shannon should know way more than
Vidal he's walked the walk he's won the
titles his record is without question
but the dalles been boxing since eight
years old and the man has an incredible
brain he is [__] smart the
relationships they have with the
fighters are so different it dolls like
a big brother at JJ Shannon seems more
like a sergeant to Logan just shouting
and screaming at him and tell him what
to do and maybe that's what they both
need maybe they need totally different
relationships with their coaches and
given the attributes that Logan has
speed power size over JJ who better to
get the most out of that than one of the
quickest most powerful not out artists
in boxing history
maybe that is a match made in heaven and
who better to avoid that than of a doll
who when you watch him fight has the
reflexes of a [__] cut and knows how
to get out the way of all of the big
shots and is a defensive minded fight
airiness a thinker merging that with the
Mayweather's defensive strategy could
work perfectly I don't know what it's
like to be trained by Shannon but I've
had many
sessions with Vittal and one thing I
will say about him is he puts you in in
fight scenarios constantly where he's
training your brain to a point where you
don't have to think when you get in the
ring now obviously you want to be
thinking when you're in the ring but
what I mean is in the split second where
punches are getting thrown you want to
have instant reflexes so that you know
how to defend yourself and you know what
shot to throw in the heat of the moment
and when JJ's in there the doll will
have him to a point where if he gets hit
in a certain place there'll be an
instant reaction where he can capitalize
on the space that is available after
Logan is thrown a shot at him now JJ has
went to the Mayweather gym and it's
quite ironic because jeff mayweather
trained shannon Brinks for his
heavyweight title and then trained the
guy who actually took it off of that is
the perfect place to be if you're gonna
out fight a bigger stronger faster guy
however has there been enough time spent
there you really learn everything to a
point where it's second nature before a
huge fight like this we don't know yet
what we do know is everyone saying he's
made massive strides since he's been at
that gym and while I don't know
firsthand what Shannon is doing with
Logan I do know an Olympic medalist who
seen one of their training sessions and
told me that Logan looks hugely improved
he looks like he's been boxing for years
putting down multiple sparring partners
in a session lasting the entire six
rounds and the type of session that made
him want to put money down whatever
Shannon's doin seems to be working in
terms of the mental game seeing them a
little over a year later it is amazing
how much they've grown up like fighter
training mans you the [__] up and
they've gone through it and they both
seem more surer than ever that they're
gonna win which just makes it really
[__] hard to predict we're finding
out now that last time Logan wasn't sure
he was gonna win and he you know it did
only just saw it clicked with him within
the weeks before he fought and that jda
wasn't training as hard as he did for
the Joella fight now they're putting
that right and I believe that I believe
that they are both more surer than ever
and that their training as hard as they
possibly can because they bought know
that they're not gonna get an easy fight
that last fight was [__] hard and yet
as hard as it was they both seemed
absolutely sure they're gonna win this
one there's a few little fat Lasorda I'm
sort of look
and for both sites worrying for them a
little bit like Logan's training out of
his back garden
it seems anyway from what the footage
I've watching it's like is that like the
best place for you like I know you've
got Shannon Briggs coming around but
there's something about the fact that
changes in the Mayweather gym that makes
it look more serious you know maybe
that's just [__] maybe it is maybe
Logan soon fine but it is a bit like
it's not really the best place for you
and similarly with JJ like earlier this
year he went on tour like should you
really be doing that when you've got a
[__] big fight coming up against this
guy like is that the best use of your
time he'd clearly put on a lot of weight
all right he was still training but he
clearly wasn't training as hard as what
he could have been otherwise you
wouldn't be putting the [__] way on
like that's just [__] he was still
training naw I take that then Logan says
he's been training every day for a
[__] year and you're like alright
that's great but he'd been training
smart for the entire time like is that
optimal or is it just hitting a [__]
speed bug you know what I mean like I
don't I don't know did JJ for example
start the serious training early enough
or has he allowed Logan to get a massive
head start on him this whole time where
that advantage that JJ had where he had
all that extra experience that Logan has
now been caught and overtaken by Logan
like those are the questions I'm left
with looking at this and they might seem
like silly questions but you know I care
about these guys and you reading a
little things you're like it's not
enough in terms of confidence or
fighters in the last fight in my opinion
weren't in the right frame of mind
JJ knew he had the experience on Logan
he'd done it before he was just feeling
himself like just be honest after that
first interview I did with him he was
walking around the kitchen in that
mansion like yeah I've got this no
problem and I was like fair [__]
player like you believe in yourself but
this is not Joe Allen Lee this is a much
bigger guy in like it's gonna be harder
and I think he admits now that that
wasn't the right frame of mind to be
login on the other hunt didn't really
know if he was capable of doing this he
had never done it before and he'd seen
Jay Jay win in the last fight and then
not only that he's coming all the way
over to a different country he's nervous
and he's telling everyone yeah I'm
definitely gonna win this fight and in
reality by his brother Jake's admission
they only really got boxing a couple of
weeks before that fight and then he's
walking offstage in the press conference
that wasn't a good look whatever was
going on in his head he did
have full belief that you could do this
so in my opinion JJ was probably a
little too confident and Logan was
probably not quite confident enough
going into that fight now the levels
have changed a bit you know JJ now
understands what he's fully going up
against
Logan's won his respect and Logan now
knows that he can do this and he's now
had 14 months to actually get Barrett
what he can do and this is confidence
coming from both of them now that comes
from having done the work we've heard
McGregor talk about this sort of stuff
before ways I'm confident because I
trained well and I know I've got the
revision done to pass this exam and they
both know they're gonna go in there and
fight much better than they did last
time and that's true self belief that's
not just chat and what that means is
that one of these two men is living in
delusion and is about to have one of the
worst wake-up calls anyone can have in
life
public humiliation on TV as someone
beats the [__] out of them and that
one's gonna be the person who doesn't
execute their game plan on fight night
so how does JJ win this fight well first
off he's got to be aware of the obvious
advantages that Logan has in terms of
the reach you know the job that Logan
kept nailing and within that first fight
there needs to be a plan for that job
first off and there will be and when he
does get inside he needs to work the
body he needs to make what happened at
the end of the fight happen sooner in
order for him to have his advantages of
movement and cardio take effect in this
fight the longer he lets Logan's stay
away from him and keep the fight at that
pace that Logan said the harder it's
gonna be for those advantages to take
effect in time to win the fight another
thing JJ can do is not allow Logan to
control the fight when Logan in the
first fight is jabbing him and taking
his time JJ has seemed a bit confused a
bit wow I wasn't expecting this like
when Logan's throwing he has to throw it
the same [__] time like to make this
a fight like what Andy Ruiz did AJ don't
just stand there and let him dictate the
pace another thing JJ can really use is
that movement that he showed later in
the fight we see no light on the feet he
was ours Logan was getting tired if he
can use that earlier and stay outside of
that jab range that logged and Scott
jump in do damage jump back out hittin
without getting here is the [__]
that's boxing like that's what he needs
to do that
he can do the damage without taking as
much as he took in the first fight and
slowly break Logan down
so you bring him into the deep waters
JJ's cordial then takes over the fight
and Logan's punching power is not as bad
as it was at the start the fight and
then go for the finish
if JJ's to win this fight that is kind
of how I say this happening where when
Logan is trying to initiate JJ turns it
into more of a fight
rough him up getting close in the clinch
land as many body shots as he can and
break Logan down and don't forget he's
training in a mere weather gym they know
they're dealing with a pretty big
puncher in Logan so the defense will
have to be superb and when Logan does go
for it which he will JJ needs to not do
what he did last time and pretty much
just stand there and take punches like
he needs to get the [__] out with a toe
cop defend yourself like the harder to
hit you know and I'm sure at the
mayweather gym he's been learning all
about that as for Logan he needs to
learn how to rest within the fight
there's times in the middle of a round
where you're not in danger and last time
he was just throwing jabs just
constantly it wasn't necessary at all
times like when you get within range get
ready to fire but like this times where
you big guy like him needs to take that
opportunity to breathe recover in the
fight and he needs to be smarter with
his choices of punches because he was
basically leading the dance the whole
entire time if he allowed JJ to come on
to him at times there's times where
you're going to catch JJ for a counter
that he never really did that at all for
the first three rounds it was all him
go go go and JJ trying to counter it's
the ones that you don't see coming that
lead to the not know and if Logan's
looking to land a power punch allowing
JJ to throw more is gonna be the best
solution for that look at Tony value
versus David here he beat him quicker in
the second fight because David Haye was
trying to rip his [__] head off Logan
then needs to have a plan in place for
when JJ looks to come inside and make it
a messy dirty fight and roughing more he
needs to be able to create that distance
again so that he can take advantage of
that reach of that power because the
closer in it gets the less his
advantages take effect but also the more
likely is to absorb body shots and the
stamina goes down in an econ fight JJ's
fight he needs to keep JJ at distance
and create the opportunity to finish the
fight and lastly for Logan
if he
JJ and I don't mean like Anthony Joshua
thought you'd hurt Ruiz but in fact he
was there ready to wreck him you know
he's really got him hurt and he needs to
judge that right you can't do an Anthony
Joshua a judge that right if he does
have him here don't wobble the ahead and
go at him you know you've got a [__]
go when the time happens because he
might not get another chance at it if
judge is allowed to recover in and take
the rounds later
now I'm gonna end it here if I was to
bet on this fight you'd be going log and
Paul with an early finish or que si in
the later rounds it's just my opinion I
know it's gonna be a great fight I'm
already proud of the lads for getting in
there and putting all on the line and
taking YouTube into the mainstream media
because that's me on it's the only time
mainstream talks about us as if we've
done something bad so congratulations to
them for that I hope they make all the
money in the [__] world and I know
that whatever happens they'll both have
their audiences they'll both be loved no
matter who loses the fight so well done
to the lads I'm looking forward to
watching it you can see my live
reactions right here on the true Jordi
YouTube channel we're doing a live
stream where I'll be very drunk I'll be
swearing I'll be shouting and loving the
fights and you can put the actual fight
on your TV and you can have us on
YouTube that you know enjoy it
subscribe for it put your notifications
on hit the like button and I'll see is
there thanks for watching
I'll see you later
[Music]